mali and television showed soldiers and
a regional governor as they reassured
villagers
the government is blaming an
al-qaeda-linked group for the violence
the government of the republic of mali
deeply regrets to inform that the
peaceful populations were the subject of
cowardly and barbaric terrorist attacks
during the nights of the 18th and 19th
of june 2022
a total of 132 civilians were killed by
ahmadu kufa's fighters masina katiba
several of the attackers have been
formally identified
a local politician says the night raids
were revenge attacks
two weeks ago the army was present on
the ground to do patrols during the
patrols there were clashes with the
terrorists and about 12 terrorists were
killed after the armed and security
forces left around 4 pm on friday the
terrorists came on about 50 to 60
motorcycles to take the town of
dayalasugu hostage
mali was plunged into crisis after a
coup in 2012. france intervened after
al-qaeda and isolink groups hijacked a
breakaway movement and seized swathes of
territory
but despite a peacekeeping mission in
northern mali armed groups continued to
operate in the vassar hell region
mali's civilian government was
overthrown in a military coup in may
last year
this latest attack raises fears that the
new military leaders are failing to
restore order barbara angopa al jazeera